FAR FROM GONE.
TIME AFTER TIME, QANON MEMBERS
STILL FIND WAYS TO KEEP THE CON
GOING.
[ CHANTING ]
>> Reporter: ON JANUARY 6th,
QANON'S PRESENCE IN THE MOB WAS
UNMISTAKABLE.
>> FREEDOM!
>> I'M HERE BECAUSE Q SENT ME.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT IS?
>>.
[ CHANTING STOP THE STEAL ]
>> Reporter: Q SUPPORTERS
BELIEVED THEN AS THEY DO NOW
THAT FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP WON THE ELECTION AND IS
NOT ONLY THE RIGHTFUL LEADER OF
THE U.S. BUT IS ALSO A KIND OF
MESSIAH WHO WILL SAVE AMERICA.
IT ALL STARTED AS PART OF AN
ONLINE CONSPIRACY FOUR YEARS
AGO.
SOMEONE STARTED POSTING CRYPTIC
MESSAGES ON AN ONLIME FORUM.
THE POSTS BEGAN SOON AFTER TRUMP
SAID THIS IN JANUARY 207.
>> COULD BE THE CALM BEFORE THE
STORM.
>> WHAT STORM, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> YOU WILL FIND OUT.
>> Reporter: THE STORM IS
INTERPRETED BY Q FOLLOWERS WHO
MEAN A DAY OF RECKONING.
THEY ARE UNDER THE DELUSION
TRUMP IS FIGHTING A HOLY WAR
AGAINST A DEEP STATE, WHICH
INCLUDES DEMOCRATS AND
CELEBRITIES WHO THEY SAY WORSHIP
WAR SHIP SATAN, MOLEST CHILDREN,
AND HARVEST THEIR BLOOD.
QANON FOLLOWERS BELIEVE TRUMP
WAS RECRUITED BY THE MILITARY TO
BRING DOWN THIS GLOBAL CABAL,
AND THAT HE WOULD DO IT BEFORE
HE LEFT OFFICE.
>> JOZEF ROBINETTE BIDEN JR. DO
COLUMNLY SWEAR.
>> Reporter: AFTER JOE BIDEN WAS
SWORN IN, THERE WAS ONE LAST
POST ON DECEMBER 8th, 2020.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW Q'S
IDENTITY.
QANON FOLLOWERS HAVE FOUND OTHER
FORUMS TO SPREAD THEIR LICE.
>> SEEN AS SINCE AFTER THE
INSURRECTION WHEN TWITTER AND
FACEBOOK REALLY STARTED KICKING
OFF A LOT OF QANON ACCOUNTS, WE
HAVE SEEN A LOT OF QANON
FOLLOWERS MOVE TO PLATFORMS LIKE
GAB.
GAB HAS BEEN AROUND A FEW YEARS
THIS.
ONE QANON GROUP CALLED QANON AND
THE GREAT AWAKENING HAS MORE
THAN 00,000 MEMBERS.
AND IF YOU ARE IN IT, YOU
BASICALLY LIVE IN A PARALLEL
UNIVERSE.
>> HEY, HEY, HEY, IT'S YOUR
FAVORITE TRUTH SEEKER HOLDING
THE LIGHT FOR EVERYONE OUT THERE
WHO HAS GIVEN UP HOPE THAT TRUMP
IS NOT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WHEN, IN FACT, HE IS.
>> Reporter: THOUGH THE GROUP
HAS FADED INTO THE SHADOWS THIS
PAST YEAR, THEIR LOYALTY REMAINS
TO ONE PERSON, FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THEY PREDICTED HE WAS GOING TO
BE REINSTATED ON MARCH 4th AND
PROCEED WITH PUBLIC EXECUTIONS
OF PEDOPHILES ON MARCH 5th.
>> EXECUTIONS WILL BE HAPPENING
ON MARCH 5th.
THAT'S A BIG STATEMENT.
AND I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO IT.
>> Reporter: WHEN THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN, Q FOLLOWERS PREDICTED
TRUMP WOULD REALLY BE REINSTATED
ON AUGUST 13th, A DAY WHICH ALSO
CAME AND WENT.
>> WE ARE Q.
WE ARE QANON.
WE ARE THE ANON.
WE FOLLOW Q.
>> Reporter: IN NOVEMBER A NEW
PREDICTION FOR TRUMP'S RETURN,
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE A SURPRISE
ANNOUNCEMENT BY JOHN F. KENNEDY
JR.
HE DIED IN A PLANE CRASH IN 1999
BUT Q FOLLOWERS BELIEVED HE
WOULD ARISE AND ANNOUNCE TRUMP'S
NEW PRESIDENCY.
HUNDREDS ARRIVED TO THE PLACE
WHERE HIS FATHER WAS
ASSASSINATED TO SEE IT HAPPEN.
SOME Q FOLLOWERS BELIEVE JOHN F.
KENNEDY AND OTHERS ARE ONLY
PRETENDING TO BE DEAD.
>> CAN YOU GIVE ME ANY NAMES?
>> MICHAEL JACKSON.
>> MICHAEL JACKSON IS COMING
BACK?
>> MICHAEL JACKSON.
ROBIN WILLIAMS.
HE WAS WITH OUR GROUP LAST
NIGHT.
>> Reporter: NONE OF THEIR
PREDICTIONS HAVE EVER COME TRUE.
SO THEY EMBRACED OTHER
CONSPIRACIES ABOUT THE ELECTIO